Hey everyone.
I'm YaYa Gosselin, and I play Sam.
And I'm Miya Cech, and I play Jade.
And we are...
The Surfside Girls!
Surfside Girls is based on the graphic novels by Kim Dwinell.
It's about these two best friends, Jade and Sam.
They've been friends for a long time.
They love surfing.
Later dude.
And they're like complete opposites.
Definitely a yin and yang situation.
Totally.
Jade Lee is this very smart, witty person.
She loves science.
She kind of sees the world as an equation.
Everything has to add up and science and logic.
Therefore, does that mean
I don't really believe in myself?
Jade. Jade. Hi. You're in a hypothesis spiral.
Sam is this bold and fearless girl.
And has a little bit of a mischievous side.
It's getting rough out there.
Maybe we should call it a day?
Never!
She also has a really big imagination.
And she's more into the supernatural than
the science side of everything.
Holy frijoles!
But what draws them together is
that love for mystery and investigating.
So mysterious.
I love it.
So Sam, one day, wipes out on her surfboard.
Sam!
And she finds this magical cavern with a doubloon.
I found this potentially cursed treasure,
and now I'm haunted by a ghost!
How hard did you hit your head?
What are you doing?
It's not until Jade sees Sam walk through a wall.
Maybe ghosts do exist.
Perhaps a 100% chance.
That's when Jade knows this is not one of Sam's stories.
This, this is real.
She saw a ghost.
Behold.
The Obsidian Flyer!
Remi is played by Spencer Hermes Rebello.
I did not know that.
Please walk me down the memory plank.
He's this funny 14 year old ghost pirate.
And I've never, ever said "Boo!" Until now.
And he is kind of childlike. Very naive and innocent.
How will we get in?
Right. I'm a ghost.
And they're going through this adventure like Three Musketeers.
And the mystery is why their beautiful cliffside, Danger Point,
is slowly eroding away, and a ghost pirate ship disappearing with it.
I fear by summer's end there will be nothing left.
So Sam and Jade need to help Remi to save Surfside.
I mean, if that whole cliff crumbles...
A horrific ancient evil will be unleashed.
(lightening cracks)
Okay let's not get dramatic.
I absolutely loved the script because it
featured two strong, minority female leads,
which I think is awesome.
They represent something so special.
I've never seen a young Mexican surfer before.
And to get to set that example for young girls,
that you can do anything.
You know, it doesn't matter what you look like.
Paddle out again?
Race you to the next one.
Have you ever surfed before?
Yeah.
You have?
Yeah, I have.
Okay, I haven't.
A little secret here:
I am not coordinated. At all.
But I got a lesson. Once I got out on the water,
it was just really wonderful.
Just like super fun, super cold.
Yeah!
I really have never had an experience like this.
Everyday it was like a new adventure.
Who knows what we'll find out.
Fans of the books are really going to be excited
to see these two girls come to life.
The Surfside Girls are back!
Definitely tell everybody.